[Music]
my wife she decided that our marriage
was over why'd she leave man she said
that she hasn't been happy for a while I
was on my way back and she called me and
said okay do you want to fix this do you
want to work on this and I said yes and
I expected her to be there when I got
bag and she was
[Music]
gone woo what's up this is John with the
Dr John on deloney show the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
show
ever so it says my
friends at the local Walgreens dude
we're so glad that you've joined us on
the
show uh we take real calls from real
people who are struggling going through
challenges in their life whether it's in
their marriage whether it's in their
dating relationship whether it's in
their with their mental or emotional
health whether it's with their kids
whatever you got going on my promise is
I'm going to sit here with you and we
are going to figure out what's the next
right move um if you want to be on the
show go to john.com
askk ask john.com ask or give me a buzz
at 1844 693
3291 it's a couple of important things
um one you can go to John dooney.com and
sign up for the newsletter I send out a
newsletter once a week um with that
points to different things sometimes
it's show clip sometimes it's breaking
down certain mental health Diagnostics
what it's got a whole bunch of stuff to
it it's pretty cool you can go to
john.com and sign up for the newsletter
to keep up to date a lot of people DM me
and ask like hey when are you come to my
city when are you come to my town when's
the next Retreat when's next whatever so
that's a great way to keep up with
whatever in the world I'm doing um and
also if you have read building a
non-anxious life and you are interested
in digging a little bit deeper I've
created an anxiety test it's not a
diagnostic it's not going to tell you
whether you have a mental health
diagnosis but it will help you kind of
Take Aim why am I so burned out why is
my alarms why are my alarms going off
all the time my anxiety alarms my stress
alarms why am I constantly just frazzled
and it will give you some insights into
some places in your life where you might
look and I took it recently I was way
more anxious in a few areas than I
thought I was and it was right on I had
kind of pinpointed I think it's because
of my kids it wasn't my kids at all it
was a couple of other areas and so it
actually pretty effective um thousands
and thousands and thousands of people
have taken the test it's awesome and we'
love to have you uh check it out you can
go to john.com and check that out all
right so we're in the questions for
human Seasons there's new questions for
humans decks out we're going to save
your Thanksgiving get on the get on the
horn um and get those questions for
humans decks but Kelly's got a question
for us to kick the show off today yeah
but before we start that I would like to
just say that as of recording this
tomorrow is tonight's game s
of the Astros versus the Rangers rers
and now this comes out just in a little
over a week so we'll be in the middle of
the World Series by the times this comes
out the Rangers will be in the middle of
the World Series will be two games up in
the World Series we be currently beating
the Phillies most likely as will be
ahead of the Phillies probably two games
to none yeah so I would just like to
point out that uh we're at War hey let's
say this we are at War and um I think we
could we need a wager on this in front
of everybody 100% agree thought cash but
I also think it would be hilarious that
the person like for real has to get the
other team tattooed on their body
no fun Ruiner org.net yeah all right
fine it'll be cash but um I have to say
as much as this pains me to say there's
been a couple of incredible pitching
performances there's been a bench
clearing brawl oh it was fantastic
wasn't it there's been a ninth inning
home run win by the Astros there's been
a ninth inning Grand Slam by the Rangers
last night it's been a heck of a series
well there's a I mean first of all it's
Texas it's two Texas teams that hate
each other and and most people don't
know if you grow up in Houston you are
trained to hate Dallas and the same I
mean to me if anyone asks me what's the
worst city in Texas Houston oh Dallas by
A Thousand Miles yeah I mean it's just
there's no question it's Houston so
except it's Dallas and so yes it's it's
a war of the ages it's a civil war
inside our own there's a lot of history
with these two teams especially going
back to you know getting hit with
hitting each I mean there's been a lot
of intentional pitchers thrown at
Players not at the bat since this
started or accidental accidental acdal
he smoked that dude totally I mean got
the bruising I can only imagine on his
98 miles hour right in just nailed
him and it just feels right it feels
like the last sport that's right it's if
you hit a home run to go up and you
dance around the bases I have to hit you
I I just think it's right it just feels
right to me well tomorrow we'll know yes
and tomorrow I will I will not rub it in
when the Astros win tonight and I'm
gonna lie y'all haven't won it home in
this whole series I don't have a good
feeling Kelly I don't which is why I'm
so glad this series is ending in Houston
because we've won all the games at
orange juice Park and we won all the
games in the big trash can in exctly
Arlington gosh I don't have a good
feeling Kelly I don't I do I don't I
don't
man hey I need this because my Cowboys
come on I need I need this I I need this
it's been quite the train wreck of a
year for me let's do this y'all have won
a World we've never won a World Series
well that's because y'all are terrible
all right go to the question let's go
questions for humans all right if the
world ran out of turkey and ham God that
would be so sad anyway what main course
would you choose for Thanksgiving
enchiladas 100% that's what I was going
to say Mexican food Thanksgiving baby
that's what I was going to say I know
people that do that I think it's
fantastic we did it a couple years when
I was a kid growing up in Texas and it
was l [__] yeah it would be a full-blown
like cheese chicken beef whole multiple
kinds of enchiladas I sometimes have
dreams about just putting my face into a
plate of enchiladas I'm good with that
around dang good enchiladas do you
you're good at it yeah that like that is
the only thing that I miss from Texas
being in Nashville is Mexican food I
went to I was in Texas three weeks ago
and I had a lot of impat
enchiladas I know that's why I don't go
in the booth for weeks after you get
back from Texas really cuz it stinks in
there Jenna what about you uh probably
pasta I could eat pasta anytime any day
I can see that give it to me I love a
good spaghetti meatballs Italian
Thanksgiving Italian Thanksgiving I love
it Joseph barbecue Barb yeah well done
oh yeah thank you cow or
Pig both that a boy I like that one very
good very good Nate
Dog um I was trying to think of
something American that reflects
Thanksgiving um some you're some dicey
ground there man yeah um hot dogs I
we'll just say penguin we'll just say we
colonize some other place we'll bring a
random bird from another Contin and eat
that be on Ice I am editing this out by
the way you can't eat a I I don't know
I've never heard of anybody eating a
penguin no that's image in my head I how
do you even come up with that gosh you
need to see a therapist all right let's
go out to Missouri and talk to the great
and wonderful Logan what up Logan how we
doing how's it going John good sorry you
had to hear that weird thing from
Nathan it's all good I'm I can double
down on the Mexican though ex yes yes
glad I'm glad you didn't say you want to
eat penguin all right so what's up man
uh so um it's been it's been a rough
month man
um what happened uh well my wife she
decided that our marriage was over and I
didn't get a confrontation I didn't get
a conversation I didn't get nothing so
uh my question to you sir is how do you
move forward when you know that you are
never going to get the closure that you
need to get past
something like
that I think there's a couple of layers
in between now and
closure um no I understand that I
understand it's going to be a process
and everything I'm just I'm very
self-aware and very you know conscious
of the process of healing from emotional
trauma and grief but it's should it this
this is a situation that I've never been
faced with in my life and I I was never
prepared for why'd she leave
man she's just she said that she hasn't
been happy for a while um we we haven't
had a proper face to-face conversation
or anything about this I'm an over the
road trucker and she told me that she
was going down to see some family for a
couple of days I got back from a run she
left when I left to you know get on the
road again she was coming back up and
then I found out all the stuff that
happened dude why aren't you on her
front porch right now wherever she
is uh because if I do I'm
probably going to get arrested not
because I'm going to do anything violent
but because the Dude thinks I'm
psychotic oh she had another guy's house
yeah she's already with another dude she
went down to go see some family but
during that time she was not seeing
family she was moving stuff in with this
dude that she just met down there which
I don't even know if it's you know is
it's a big mess and she didn't just meet
him dude I know I know
yeah it it's clearly been happening for
a while apparently the conversation that
I've heard is because this dude's ex
contacted my mom and started asking
questions and like it got it got all
kind of Twisted but that's how I found
out like this dude his ex contacted my
mom my mom contacted me like hey
something's going down I just feel like
there's a group of people in the
background going Jerry Jerry just
chanting I know right I know all right
so if she if she got in a car if she
knocked on on the door or you're sitting
there watching TV tonight and she walked
in the front door are you having her
back or is your marriage
over I
mean answer just straight answer as
straight as you can answer all right as
straight as it can be yeah 99.9% no
no your marriage is
over like yeah like okay because some of
the things that have been said yeah
can't be taken back and they cannot be
taken lightly well lying to you and
moving out and moving in with some other
guy and sleeping with him for the last
how month that shouldn't be lightly
either no yeah I I but the thing is like
I we when I was out on a run when all of
this went down m M I was on my way back
and she called me and said okay do you
want to fix this do you want to work on
this and I said yes and I expected her
to be there when I got back and she was
gone so did y'all have a big blow up
that she finally just said enough's
enough there there was no big blow up I
didn't even know she was unhappy like
for the last year and a half it's been
rough because that's how long I've been
driving truck for okay and I always
tried to get her to come on the road
with me I always tried to get her to you
know do things with me when I was home
but she always prioritized her friends
and she always had some reason not to
come on the road with me so she's been
out of this marriage for a long time I
know that now I didn't realize it at the
time sure and so one of the scariest
things about finding out your spouse has
cheated on
you one is that picture you have in your
head of her having sex with somebody
else right there's that very visceral
reality right and that was eating me up
for like is the first two weeks of all
of this and now it's like I've just for
some reason the last week or so I've
been able to push that out of my head
I've just not been able to think about
that fantastic yes yes and and I want to
tell you something thinking about that
over time is a choice you can't help the
lightning bolt the image that just
shoots in your head you can choose to
hit play on that vide tape that's
looping in your head okay okay that's
number one and most people think that um
finding out your spouse your girlfriend
your boyfriend is cheating on you that
that is the worst part it's
not the worst part is realizing what
you're realizing in slow motion right
now and you no longer trust
Logan yeah because you missed it yeah
for two years your wife's been out of
this thing and you didn't know and you
were busting your butt to get certif
you've been busting your butt to give
her a better life by driving right yeah
and you pictur over the last few weeks
that it has felt like a very one-sided
marriage for a lot longer than I
realized that's right I was putting in
all of this work and all this effort to
keep providing and making sure that she
didn't have to do things she didn't want
to do I've paid for cruises I've paid
for trips I've paid for girls trip and
I'm just like okay but when am I going
to get those things and it never came
yeah and
so you find yourself on really un like
kind of you're out on a lake that's
Frozen and all the ice is cracking
around you yeah right and that's a scary
feeling not being able to trust your own
gut and your own
intuition so there's a couple of things
that are important number one uh my
friend Dave says this and I love it when
somebody leaves you when your marriage
is over
the relationship has ended the Romantic
relationship has ended the Friendship at
the time has ended I think friendships
can happen down the road um when things
are trust reestablished and this isn't
every group I know there's people who
consciously uncouple and they hold hands
down to the courthouse to get divorced
and that's a whole other conversation
but this is now a business
transaction my dad has been saying that
for so long it's a business transaction
is she in your car
uh no not anymore um actually she was in
my vehicle she's she was driving my car
for like three years and she used my car
that I came into this marriage with to
go and do all of this stuff and then
just last week we managed to or my
lawyer convinced her to come up and swap
her out of my vehicle into another
vehicle that we had that we were both on
the time for and she was never on the
title for my car so I'm glad I got that
so this is now a business transaction
she's made an a grown-up choice and with
that grownup choice is going to come a
lot of grown-up consequences
okay it's also going to cost you some
it's going to suck it's going to be
hard I want you to stop texting
her I haven't she she cut off her phone
she disconnected her phone and
everything okay I have no contact okay I
want you to let your attorney do his job
or her job
okay and then the second thing is is
good oldfashioned
grief and you cannot do this by
yourself I have a fantastic support
structure good like those first two days
when I found out everything and you know
all the thoughts were running through my
head if I didn't have my family I don't
think I could have been doing my job and
functioning as a person at all yeah I'm
amazing you're even still standing
upright but here's what that looks like
that looks like you getting two or three
people and you all go to dinner when are
you doing local or are you doing weekl
long runs about week long runs I'm on a
run to Oregon now okay so when you get
done from a run how long are you at home
before you turn on and go back out uh
two to three days four you have to
prioritize those two to three days you
got to get your laundry done you got to
go to the bank you gotta get a haircut
you gotta do that stuff but also you got
to have a dinner or a breakfast with the
guys
yep and you have to have the courage all
those thoughts you're having when you're
out on the road all the anger all the
frustration all the tears all the
singing all the yelling you have to have
the courage to write that stuff down or
if you want to be safer D speak it into
a like a phone app while you're driving
you have to have the courage to sit down
and tell those guys out loud what you're
going through in real
time yeah if I if I didn't have the
people that I have I would falling apart
I know Hey listen you're going to fall
apart be more great I can't be not I
cannot be more grateful for the people
that I have around me um
goodly this best friends well I I want
you not to just talk to him on the phone
and I just text them I want you to sit
in face to face with them if you can and
yeah this
imaginary you have fantasized already
about a couple of things finding this
guy in a dark alley and doing your worst
you have
actually it never crossed my mind
because I never blamed the guy oh it's
crossing my mind for you he's not the
one who did this this was her decision
completely I mean he's with a married
woman but but I get I get your sentiment
I I agree I I agree with that sentiment
and I I completely understand where
you're coming from but he made this
Choice well that's a
very that's very wise of you good for
you it's very mature of you you're more
mature than I would be being but the
second thing is there is not going to be
some magic
um if you had 30 minutes with her just
to just to say everything you needed to
say you wouldn't feel better when it was
over on this side of it you think you
would you
wouldn't there's no magic cathar
catharsis this this
ah it won't
exist it won't
exist
and so the hardest thing you have to do
is let go of the fantasy that if you
just had a conversation if you just knew
why if you just fill in the blank that
all this would feel different and I
think at this point it wouldn't what
with what's happened has
happened it's just
heartbreaking and I want you to not do
anything drastic or anything wild for 6
months I want you to keep meeting with
your buddies once a week and your family
whoever it is that's your support
network I want you all to meet in person
I want you to talk about what you're
struggling
with and my guess is if you've lived in
a marriage where you've been trying and
trying and trying and trying and there's
all this deception going on underneath
the underneath the water um you're going
to find strange pockets of Peace too the
sun's going to come out in places that
you didn't know the sun had gone down
and I want you to lean into
that and I want you to make sure you
take care of your body EX exercise want
you to eat as clean as you can even
though you're on the road I know it's
very very hard want you to be
intentional want you to sleep when you
can I've see guys out at some on some of
the side trucks they've got kettle bells
on the side of their with with they're
out there doing their workouts with
their kettle bells outside their their
rigs I want that to be you I want you to
take care of
yourself I want you to look up in six
months and I don't want you to have
bought a bunch of stupid crap I want you
to be in relatively good health I want
this divorce I want your attorney to
have been doing their job and kicking
butt for
you I don't want you to be in a season
of grief heartbreak maybe take a journal
with you and write down at night when
you're sleeping in the back of your rig
write down how you feel which sounds so
cheesy and lame I know I know I know
write that stuff
down then is 7 months 8 months 9 months
once you start coming up from Air I I
want you to give me a call back then
there's not a thing that you can do
right now that's just going to snap your
fingers you're caught in a in a river
that's running fast and you're going to
hang on to your buddies and you're going
to ride this one
out and I want you to be healthy and
smart as you do it and I'm so so sorry
for you I'm glad that you're not talking
to her I'm glad you're not communicating
with her I don't want you talking to her
friends or this guy's ex just get out of
the drama get out of the drama and in
these kind of situations there's a high
rate that she calls you at some point
can we talk no no you talk to my
attorney you made your grownup decision
and now you're going to have to live
with the grown-up
consequences and I'm heartbroken for you
brother I really
am yeah heart broken for you call me
anytime if I can help man' we'll be
thinking about you Logan we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks Stallone here sometimes
we know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
dealone all right let's run out to New
Jersey and talk to Maggie what up Maggie
how we doing hey just partying what are
you doing we are partying until the
wheels are falling
off not true at all we're being kind of
boring actually Maggie what's
up uh I have a question what's
up my uh fiance lied to me for five
years about a day trading count he had
uh oh he yeah he claims he made uh
200,000 and lost it all and during that
time I paid all the bills and I wound up
doubling the mortgage on my house and
I'm having a real hard time moving past
this even though I found out in
February
huh you doubled your mortgage or you've
been doubling up on your
mortgage I had to uh I had to refinance
or twice Oh
shoot what has he been
doing well now he's been trying to
rectify the situation by working his
tail off and trying to get his account
back but and other than this he was the
perfect guy he was the perfect partner
no he wasn't and no he wasn't and I'm
older and I just I'm like I do not want
to have to start again you're right he
wasn't and if he's lying to you about
this he's lying to you about other
things and you know
that I I really don't though he SW I I
think I he swears no has he given you a
print out of the last five years of this
trading
account yes I've seen all the I've seen
all the information there's been total
transparency moving
forward and so why are you choosing to
let what happened you you chose to
stay and so you've been choosing since
February to not move past this how
come I think I've got a couple scking
points that are that are getting to me
what are
they one is I think I I can't get past
grieving the life I was promised okay uh
another one is how elaborate the lies I
was told are because he was you know he
was said he was going to take the money
out but then he couldn't access the
money so that just got crazy
um and I just I have a hard time
thinking that you know somebody who
really loved me would not do this to me
yeah and I'm having a hard time trusting
myself I I I think this that's what was
the hardest part like yeah I just told
that last caller that did you hear that
I just told the last caller when
somebody cheats on you which is what he
did he cheated on you yes
um there's the cheating there's the
imagining your spouse with somebody else
right that actual physical act of him
sleeping with somebody else there's the
thought
of the actual picture of you going to
work or you going to the bank to pull
out a second mortgage and him watching
you go knowing he's got this other
account there's that image right which
is
devastating and underneath that is what
I think is a scarier Prospect which is
Maggie no longer trusts
Maggie yep and that's
unnerving especially at my age and I've
been through a lot all my previous
relationships were abusive of course and
I I really worked really hard to you
know go to therapy get myself right
get right in my head you know deal with
everything and now it's just all that's
been kind of shattered again
yeah why are you still with this guy yes
why
Ah that's a good
question part of it's Financial we live
together and we have to um part of it
100% don't agree with
that it's not true that's a story you're
telling yourself for the life that you
want you're willing to share a bed with
somebody that you don't love or maybe
you love the idea of them but someone
who hurt you deeply and you're still
unable to no I love him I love him
completely I know I do okay so someone
you love but also somebody who hurts you
and you can't fully exhale in your own
home what else why else do you think you
can't you're still with them
um I think that I don't want to start
over again at my age what you keep
mentioning your age how old are you I'm
54 I'll be 55 next year so what are you
willing to put up with if you had slept
with your friend would that be
enough that would not be tolerated I
know this is this is the same thing I
get it it's it's Financial um infidelity
it's it's the same thing I totally get
that
have you ever y'all sat down and pulled
his credit
report yep and there's no other accounts
on
there
nope this was just a one-time isolated
thing where he was running how much did
he did he get and
lose
200k how does somebody filter 200 ,000
in and out of their
relationship does he make that kind of
money or did you turn your a blind eye I
turned a blind eye like I did in my
other relationships and that's another
problem I'm having with myself right now
yeah so are you mad at him or are you
mad at Maggie that you went through all
this counseling you've been through hell
and back and then here you go
again both
okay here's the hard truth I'm going to
give you because I love you m you've
chosen to
stay you've chosen to allow him to stay
in your
home and every day you're choosing
misery and I would suggest you need to
make one or two different
choices either I don't feel miserable
every day though but I'm listening go
ahead I'm
sorry you you have learned the skill
over years of your
life to
smile to brush things under the rug and
to take how Maggie feels about something
and shove it so far down that you can
get through a day true or
false 100%
yeah the only problem is as the great
Bessel vender culk says the body keeps
the score you can't outrun your nervous
system so while you're like everything's
great in one wonderful and I know where
all the money is and it's all good and
he's still handsome and I'm not alone
and I'm so desperate to not be
alone I'll settle for this because it's
all
okay your nervous system says that guy's
not
safe or maybe it's saying Maggie you're
not safe again you're not safe again
you're not trustworthy
again Fair
it's it's all directed at me you're
right what happened to Maggie that you
think so little of
Maggie lots of abuse yeah narcissistic
abuse for about pretty much my whole
life I'm sorry parental than than an
ex-husband yeah
yeah and I think you know I thought I'd
move past everything I mean I'd been in
therapy for years and years years and
years you know I left my ex-husband I
got right in my head I you know I did
all the therapy I had to do there and
now then this happen yeah thing about
therapy thought was a perfect
relationship yeah turns out to be just
the same as the other one just different
right better but yeah some similarities
for
sure so how can I
help I need to know what to do what to
do for
what I probably already know what to do
don't I well I mean it's it's if you
were my sister I would tell
you strongly consider taking a break
because your B you haven't slept
yet if you were my sister I would put my
hand on both sides of your face and I
look you as deep into your eyes as I
could and I would tell you I love you
and you're worth more than this
you're worth a more than yet another
abusive relationship except the abuse
here is with somebody who's kind instead
of somebody who
yells he's kind and sweet and
loving and he watched his fiance or his
wife continue to shovel the hole to Hell
deeper and deeper and deeper while he
was over here
playing playing Le DiCaprio at the at
the roulette
table except he called it Wall
Street that is nothing I have not
said and you're worth more than
that I know I am there's one of two
things happening here either in your
guts deep in your guts you know there's
other things out
there you know the truth is not fully on
the table that's one or two
you have not fully come back to the
table which I'll say in a in a kind of a
Twist is cruel to
him because if you say you're going to
stay he messed up and he messed up bad
and then he lied to you and lied to you
and lied to you and together yall dug
quite a hole for
yourselves you are the one who went and
got a second mortgage and a third
mortgage that was a choice you made mhm
absolutely so here's the
hole but if you said I'm all in I
forgive you you've come clean here's all
the information on the
table but you're still one foot out
that's cruel it's not
cool you're absolutely right and and I I
do know that and I I've believe me I've
been back and forth and back and forth
and I that that makes me feel as bad as
anything else well I mean feeling bad is
not going to solve it you know what I
mean it's a matter it's a it's a matter
of saying
okay I'm going to try for 30 days to be
Allin what does that mean that means I'm
going to carry a journal with me at all
times okay and every time I have get a
sense in my gut that he's not telling
the truth I'm G to write it down okay
every time I get a sense in my gut that
something's not right doesn't feel right
I'm going to write it down I'm going to
stop where I'm at kind of like when I
first started counting calories when I
had to get control of my eating every
meal I stepped into the bathroom and
pulled my phone out to put it into this
little app I have it was so annoying and
it was every single
time and that's how over time I learned
to trust my body to trust what in on the
plate in front of me to trust all the
things see what I'm saying yeah I need
to see the patterns got to start is my
body crazy is there something else here
or is this part of the healing
journey and every time you have a uh you
feel something bubbling up say the words
out loud I'm feeling vulnerable here
honey
and I'm feeling a distance between us
I'm feeling a sense of panic I'm feeling
a sense of anxiety I'm feeling a sense
of I have one of the old thoughts
zooming back in my head and it's just
sending me off into a tail spin for a
second I'm going to go for a walk I'll
be right
back and what you're doing is you're
practic in taking control of your body
back see what I'm saying absolutely the
work Mak perfect sense it's just hard
it's gonna be
hard nothing's fun about it but are you
convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
that he's been completely open with you
100%
Allin since it happened uhhuh yes I am I
am yes do you think things happened
before
and uh he just didn't tell you
everything um I think it was a lot of
panic and him lying to himself and him
setting unrealistic goals for himself
because of the goals he had for our
relationship okay I think if I didn't
feel that way I wouldn't be able to
forgive him if I don't know if that
makes sense but that he got he was
trying to he's trying to do something
beautiful and then he freaked out and it
went sideways and then he freaked out
and freaked out and freaked out and then
he dug himself huge
mess yeah that's what I think happened
okay that's very um very optimistic of
you I know and I know that's very
generous but after hours of conversation
I have come to that conclusion okay then
I think you're your decision moving
forward is am I gon to forgive Maggie
for having missed it
again
yep right and maybe every time it
bubbles up your conversation is not with
him but it's with Maggie
Maggie we missed it and we're we're
we're back
now right because I look at the budget
every
week I look at our accounts every week
he brings home I look at them every day
yeah he brings home his he brings home
his pay stub every week and I see
it right you see what I'm saying no
absolutely and so I think it's just a
matter of slow learning how to trust
Maggie and I I don't know a way to do
this without writing it down getting it
out of your body onto a piece of
paper I don't know I was talking to my
friend Dr Steven Bonner today um who's a
coach and he I we're just talking about
that exact thing I don't know a path
forward unless you get it out of your
body onto paper and so carry a journal
with
you maybe ask yourself is this about him
or is this about
Maggie how could I do this again I'm
learning I'm learning how in the world
could I get with another abusive guy
that doesn't tell me the truth that dug
a hole like this how in the world could
I go take out a second and third
mortgage on my house instead of just
selling it and moving to an apartment
how in the world did I let that happen I
did I'm going own reality I'm going to
choose reality and I'm going to move
forward hang on the line here I'm going
to send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life I want youall to work
through this book
together I want you to work through it
together I'm going to send you two
copies he's going to read one you're
going to read one you're going to read a
chapter together at kind of a marriage
book okay the other thing I'm going to
send you is Financial Peace University
and every dollar app it's the best
financial plan for getting out of debt
digging yourself out of a humongous
freaking hole on the planet and it's the
app that you can share together that
keeps both of you all on the same page
for a year I'm going to send it it's the
one that links up to your bank account
so you don't have to pull the accounts
up all the time you're just going to
have it on the
app so I'm giving you the
tools but I want you your your job is to
a use the tools and B go get a journal
and start writing every time you have a
feeling every time you have a mistrust
every time you have a gut reaction every
time you want to punch him or every time
you look in the mirror and go you idiot
want you to write that down write that
down write that
down it's time to be done talking and
it's time to to start
acting okay I want you to call me back
in 6 months and I want you to tell me
where you're at how you're feeling
what's the state of your relationship
I think personally you're being very
very very generous to him I think
there's other things there but I trust
you cuz I'm not
there but man my spidey sense says
there's some other stuff other stuff
but all
good call me back in 6 months and let me
know how you're doing we'll be thinking
about you Maggie we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to to get started that's 3 months
for free to prioritize your mental and
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music through guided prayers meditation
and more and by the way hallow isn't
just Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition or if you
don't have a faith tradition it's a
great place to start from scripture
readings to prayers to journaling Hall
makes it easy to practice mindfulness
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and choose peace remember hallow is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone today to
start your free trial just follow the
simple prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to Hartford Conneticut and talk to the
mighty Nick what's up Nick hello Dr
deloney what up
not much how about you rocking on to the
break of dawn my brother what about you
that's great I consider myself fortunate
to be speaking to such an experienced
and knowledgeable person such as
yourself and I just wanted to state I'm
starting your book I'm looking forward
to embracing its lessons and thank you
for your hard work well thank you dude
appreciate you how can I help man let's
see how do I move forward after a
turbulent romantic relationship how do I
recover when I feel so unattractive in
dating and how do I give in dating when
I felt like that's that's all I do and
if I can give you a little bit of
context yeah go for it uh on on paper
I'm successful I have money saved I have
good safe home healthy supportive family
and friends including two married
Brothers with three kids each I have a
good paying union job and I volunteer in
the community I work out and I eat
healthy so I have a positive romantic
I've had positive romantic relationships
but the last few were unhealthy without
using the label of borderline I had a
girlfriend of about 9 months who
exhibited all the DSM symptoms of border
line then my most recent
relationship I um of about 10 months
ended in June and was extremely
turbulent she's diagnosed bipolar 1 type
one and around June stated she was very
sorry as she was Rapid Cycling she was
manipulative abusive and became a
heavier
Drinker as you've mentioned in the show
before I felt so utilitarian and she
consumed all my energy and then since
June she claimed I abused her is suing
me in small claims court and she's been
doing almost anything she can to make my
post Rel relationship life difficult and
everyone in my family is seeing this
unhealthy and perilous result as this
could impact my job and overall I just
feel beat up I felt like my love and
giving nature were exploited I feel like
this extra challenge in trusting woman
again and even some ways trusting myself
and I feel so isolated unfulfilled and
partially because I think she's behind
me getting banned from a dating website
to move forward and I'm not thriving
after all this and I just feel like I'm
alone yeah man you got you got your
heart broken and you got
burned yeah like um you're not crazy
man I don't take it like
uh have you ever done martial arts or
anything no okay I remember the first
time this awesome guy named sonado
knocked me
out he uh was was a great boxer and he
just smoked me just melted me with a
shot with a with a punch and I slumped
over up against the wall in our gym and
I crashed to the floor and I got up and
it was quick and I had a bad headache
and I was kind of just wobbly somebody
took me
home and the next day I was out and
don't everyone to do this again this
sucks this is the worst this is
awful mhm and then about two no about a
week later I went back just to
watch I ended up doing a few
drills the next day I was back on the
mats doing Jiu-Jitsu stuff you see what
I'm
saying I got smoked
man I needed a
break you got smoked you got hurt yeah
and it sounds like the best parts of you
the guy who you are sounds like you're a
giving guy sounds like you're a guy who
works really hard sounds like you're a
guy who does his best to love people in
his community and his
Circle and there's something super
unsettling when somebody takes that love
and compassion and weaponizes it against
you exactly you can check in on somebody
like hey are you okay are you okay and
then they say he's harassing
me or you go pick somebody up who's had
too much to drink and they say you know
he picked me up or what whatever the
thing is and you're just sitting they
going what right
mhm I would think if you were ready to
jump back into a dating
relationship that if I was your friend I
would tell you please don't do that
please take some time to
heal okay you see what I'm saying let me
ask you a hard question you gave me a
whole bunch of really impressive
external
metrics do you like
Nick
I I like me I think I have good value I
just I think usually romantic
relationships it just it doesn't show
through especially at the start why not
so why
not um because it sounds like you're a
guy that's doing a whole lot of
exhausting performing to make sure that
you present the right
way and I just like
Nick uh
yeah I I believe that other people may
have more I don't know exciting lives or
something like that um
why
why what makes you
unexciting I I I feel like some of it
comes from just I don't even though I do
all this I feel like I lack confidence
yeah so it doesn't really come through
to people and so when I bring anything I
do have that's uh of value and kind of
spontaneous or exciting it just I don't
know I feel like that's not something
that's really um attractive at the
moment or attractive to a date or
something I don't know yeah I think
that's a story you're telling yourself
brother because the way you introduced
yourself to
me is not dude I'm an awesome younger
brother of Two Awesome Brothers I'm a
member of my community uh you introduced
me yourself to me by a bunch of stuff
you have and just a bunch of stuff
you've done you handed me a resume of
you yeah and I don't when I used to hire
people the resume got you in the door I
didn't care about the resume when you
got in there I want to know
you and you're walking around with a
story saying I'm uninteresting and so
the only way I can be of any sort of
value in a relationship is to let people
know I make good money I got a nice car
I've got a nice house I'm
safe and my brothers are happily married
and if you were going to date my
daughter I would tell her to run from
you because that is a guy who is coming
in so guarded up that it's going to take
a long time to get to know you and I
mean this with all due
respect the only people who are going to
be attracted to all these external
metrics are people who are grasping at
their own
straws see what I'm saying yeah and
you're going to create this dance over
over and over again because if you walk
if you walked into a group of people
that I hang out with a group of women
that I hang out with and we're like hi
my name is Nick I have a great job I
have a great car I have a nice safe
house they'd be like all right dude I'm
out if you walk into a group of people
who are struggling for any sort of
security at
all they're going to latch on to
that but if you walked into a room
confident because you have a nice home
and you got a good job it might be
boring a lot of us have boring jobs you
know what I mean my job looks unboringed
my day spent in meetings and reading
nerdy Journal articles right and trying
to like write a talk very little of my
day is actually in front of a microphone
or on a stage and so all of us have
boring jobs boring parts of our
job it's knowing no I put the work in
man I'm a catch I'm freaking Nick I'm a
catch hey what's up my name is Nick I
like punk rock music what about
you but you can only get there if you
like
Nick okay what are you what are you into
what do you
like um I love going to museums I'm
actually I graduated U with a degree in
art so I like art um I like rock indoor
rock climbing these days so I like to be
active I like like being outside
bicycling what kind of art do you
like uh painting
Landscapes who in the world told you
that's
boring
uh I don't know where it is that came
from it's absolutely Stone
nonsense
mhm you have an art degree and you have
a good job both of those things yeah
that makes you a unicorn
Nick you know I mean most of my friends
with art
degrees don't have stable homes and good
jobs and I'm just kind of laughing
because those are my
buddies well and I i' believe enough I'm
a firefighter EMT and so it's kind of on
the other side of the
map my gosh okay so you're a guy who is
not willing who is willing to go in and
do dangerous things on behalf of his
community you like art you also like
Fitness where is this story coming from
that you're
boring that you need to lead with your
car and square footage of your
home lead with
artist lead with I'm obsessed with
landscape photography and paintings oh
and by the way if you're ever having
um congestive heart failure I can help
oh and by the way let's go rock
climbing good gosh dude the line of
people who are going to want to date you
is going to be down the road here's the
scary thing I think you need to
metabolize okay okay if you find an
amazing woman to date you it will not
heal
you m that hole you feel will not come
from the outside
okay you know what I'm saying yes
absolutely Bro you've got a lot to
offer beyond your car and job
and
home
MH do you believe
me yeah I I believe you I believe you I
trust you con conceptually yeah what
yeah it's I think part partly I I felt
like this because it's almost in some
ways it's as I became more successful on
that paper in a way like some of the
relationships may maybe this like
validates what you're saying of like I
was kind of attracting the wrong kind of
people because I was I was looking
better on paper in some ways and being
uh higher value in a way and then it
just but I didn't have the confidence
still and so it attracted like kind of
the the per people people that can kind
of latch on to that and kind of just
consume yeah consume is the great word
they're vampires they want the external
metrics yeah because for some reason
they believe they'll be safer if the
person they're with has a car and job X
and whatever and there's some truth to
that right I mean if you have those
things you're always going to eat right
you're always going to have air
conditioning and that roof over your
head those are important things
yes I think I've talked about this on
the show but there was a really
important moment this last year when my
wife and I had a great interaction um it
wasn't great at the time but it's become
one of the most important ones of our
marriage and of my whole
life when she was like
Hey like how much I love you for how
much money you make that's
full go chase these certificates and
these Awards and these bestseller go do
all that you
want but I love you as much as I'm going
to love you
and she's like I don't I don't I don't
care if we don't get another plaque on
the wall down in the basement that says
that X number of people bought your book
she goes I love
you yeah and dude that was hard for me
to
reconcile but it came down to I didn't
so much like me that
much and some some small steps sorry go
ahead well sometimes that's getting
separate from the things that make us
come alive when's the last time you
painted
something uh actually yeah it was before
the relationship there you go
yeah well a year I want you to spend
some time over the next two to three
weeks painting Something
Beautiful okay I can do
that I want you to spend some time over
the next two or three weeks hanging out
with a couple of just dude
buddies with no no intent to go get
girls y'all just go hang
out go golfing go fishing go to a game
go do
something
okay but tell
jokes talk about music talk about art
talk about rock climbing and the weirdos
in the rock climbing
Community you see what I'm saying I want
you to Circle back to humanity
cuz what's going to happen is you're
going to find somebody that falls in
love with who Nick actually is and the
stability that you're anchored into
you're a hard worker you got a good job
you got a house that's going to be bonus
that's going to be on top
of her actually loving the real guy not
just the the dog and pony show because
jobs are going to come and
go yeah cars come and go
but Nick the guy who loves art the guy
who works really hard the guy who wants
to be a good Steward of his body the guy
who loves people so much that it got
himself in trouble with this last
girlfriend that guy's etched in stone
that's who you are and that guy's worth
falling in love
with does that make sense absolutely
thank you yes I want you to you don't
have to send me the original but I want
you to take a picture of your landscape
and I I want you to send it to me direct
message or email it to the show and um
we'll put it up on the screen uh and let
everybody see
it I'll give you a homework assignment
you got a couple of weeks I want to see
that I want to see that that beautiful
painting I want you to get back in touch
with being still and seeing something
beautiful and creating something
beautiful and reconnecting with Nick cuz
Nick's worth more than the car he drives
and the house he lives in and the job he
has those things are all important don't
get me wrong that's not
Nick Nick's bigger than that appreciate
you my brother we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else of the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
dooney.com
all right we're back hey it's time for
another installment of I'm the problem
is it me is that how I I didn't know if
you were asking me a question yes it's
it's you I say that wrong every time all
right so am I the problem whatever you
want to call let go with it all right
let's do it this is a short one this is
from
Shelby one of my sisters is separated
from my brother-in-law not yet divorced
and recently started dating a guy who is
fresh out of jail on drug charges heyo
he's a recovering addict two years sober
from pictures he looks really rough
multiple facial tattoos missing teeth
Etc she's upset because none of us want
to meet him and are not interested in
being around him am I the problem for
wanting to stay far away from them both
no here's let's take face tattoos
missing teeth jail time let's take all
that
out you get to decide who you want to
spend time with
period if um you're ugly about it and
you're a jerk and disrespectful then I
would say you're the problem but you get
to say I'm not interested in being
around that person but thank you and I
don't think that makes you the problem I
think that your sister's not going to
react well to that um sometimes not
being the problem doesn't mean
everything's smooth what do you think I
don't know I can this is one where I can
see either side um of at some point if
they
continue maybe they has the guy has he's
sober changed he's changed and I mean
God knows we're all you know we don't
want to be judged by our past mistakes
um and especially Joe right I know and I
mean you know I love post Malone and
he's got a ton of face tattoos right um
but that's why I think those kind of
things are irrelevant you have an
interaction with somebody and you're not
into it cool I think at some point if
this looks like it might go somewhere
you need to make an um not an effort but
you need to meet the person and see oh
for yourself yeah are you making a
judgment but especially if it's just
somebody she's
dating I don't think that that's there's
also there's a deeper issue which is I
you're your divorce isn't even Inked yet
I'm not interested in meeting the person
you already running around with right
but I'm I'm not yeah I'm good thanks
yeah um and I mean what's the re what's
the the chance that this is meant to be
forever and ever and this is going to be
forever sure you've got a bunch of
facial tattoos and Robert's still
hunging in there with you well
yeah it's just with our life and
everything we agreed many years ago that
no one else was going to step into our
chaos yeah so we were just stuck might
as well make the sucker work it's either
this or nothing yeah facial tattoos be
damned yeah if you ever were with
somebody else they would be stunned when
you washed your makeup off and saw all
the tattoos on your forehead above your
eyebrow are you telling me you lied to
that poor guy this weekend at money and
marriage who asked you if I had tattoos
oh yeah hey everybody listening to the
show so great this guy comes up um we're
in a signing line and um taking a
picture with this couple and he pulls me
aside and a lot of times in signing
lines people pull me aside and like hey
my son's struggling with addiction or my
daughter's you know coming around or you
help with our marriage thank you so much
like really kind things or deep things
and he says hey you got a second man and
I was like yeah real quick because we're
we got a long line and he goes hey man
um does Kelly really have that many
tattoos and I was like dude I haven't
even scratched the surface yet I haven't
even scratched the surface when you see
the Old English tattoos coming out of
the back of her Jorts that she wears
it's
unbelievable yeah it's pretty amazing
none whatever zero lying to America hey
I love you guys I'm grateful that you
spend your time with us thank you so so
much hey if you want to send in uh am I
the problem is it me go to john.com
and put that in the header and send it
in and we'll get it out hey love you
guys see
you